there is new fallout tonight in the
college bribery scandal the families of
Felicity Huffman and Lori Lachlan both
suffering the consequences of their
alleged involvement we're coming back at
our old salary nut up in the wake of the
massive College scandal Lori's future on
fuller house hangs in the balance I love
that job I had a hair person a makeup
person I want to miss all my persons
et has learned the fifth and final
season of the Netflix it is not in
production yet it wouldn't be difficult
for writers to cut Aunt Becky out since
she doesn't play a major role in the
reboot so it's like the previous happens
everyone drops in for about three
episodes Lori's on-screen husband John
Stamos took to Instagram in hopes of
lightening the mood he posted this
adorable video of eleven month old son
filly laughing the caption quote for
those of us who just need a good smile
right now
two months ago John appeared with Lori
on her daughter Olivia's YouTube channel
I love you good girl yeah good values
and you project good morals I'm like the
USC freshman and her older sister Bella
both now face possible expulsion by the
University but a source tells ET they
are worried about being bullied and will
likely not return on their own and
before I went to college I was super
naive and ignorant and dumb and I was
like I'm not going to college cuz I want
an education now that I'm here it's like
actually really interesting and I love
it and that's why I'm still here so far
a Sephora and Tresemme have dropped
their partnership with Olivia and as for
Lori her career at the Hallmark Channel
is finished for now she's involved in
some pretty intense investigations the
network confirms they have canceled her
TV movie series garage-sale mysteries
and she will either be recast or cut out
of Hallmark's highly rated original
series when calls the heart today
Felicity Huffman and husband William H
Macy's showed up to federal court in LA
the reason for their return is unclear
but Felicity and others are now being
sued for 500 billion dollars after angry
parents and students filed a
class-action suit claiming they were
denied a fair chance it's just not not
fair
ma'am you're gonna have to come with us
it's also now incredibly eerie to
re-watch certain Desperate Housewives
scenes filmed more than a decade before
Felicity was arrested in real
coming from Richard in season one
Huffman's character discusses a payout
to get her kids into private school
how generous fifteen thousand that's the
same amount
authorities say felicity paid to help
her daughter get into college now could
all the fallout put Felicity's future
projects in jeopardy he'll bring in
every kid who was in the park last night
her voice can be heard in the trailer
for Ava Duvernay Central Park five
inspired series when they see us
Felicity plays a prominent role in this
series premiering in May on Netflix the
streaming service shot another project
with felicity expected to debut this
year
Netflix wouldn't comment on either but
the Hollywood Shae isn't stopping
Chrissy kind of photoshop's you guys's
faces on some potential collegiate
athletes just trying to get into college
you know what you got to do these days
John Legend poked fun at the scandal
last night with et but also had this
message a lot of people look at this
rightly as fraudulent and dishonest but
the bottom line is the system's been
rigged for wealthy people for a long
time
[Music]
[Applause]